ok non è
[Musica]
è mai sufficiente
lo faccio un'introduzione breve nella
missione precedenza a questa il tizio
col fantasma che è comparso ci aveva di
buona è un galeone che dobbiamo
inseguiva c'è tutta la missione dei
fantasmi eccetera
e alla fine per sbaglio e vogliamo un
signore oscuro questo signore oscuro ora
vuole impossessarsi di tutti i mari a
questo è il seguito non so
niente
ma poi bobo anno guarda guarda verbali e
lanterne disattesi e che sta ridendo
scusa è vero ti fa vedere il percorso
eccolo riccardo grazie card aperta la
porta
meraviglioso
minchia attenzione che corriamo perchè
te sto casino è il tizio all oscuro che
dicevo sociale che ci sono ma stabili
tanta ma dove siamo riusciti siamo
usciti respira con le bolle entrambe
monitorare nando ma come e nando ci ha
seguito di non consiste qui tutte le
abilità cm ala wire che testata non ho
pagato nelle rocce a si continua qua
sotto e ragazzi continuato assolto
quest'anno come si apre a prepari le
altre quali sono le incendiarie quindi
guardate rischio la soprano cinzia
indiani
[Musica]
a meno che non abbiamo acceso
può essere potrebbe darmi via vai mamma
mia che si è chiusa la cina dove grande
va bene bravo bravissimo e deve saltare
la scusa che tocca salta vediamo però io
invece fatto fatto lo voglio vedere
vailatti è un fortissimi raga qua ma
questa all'accaduto
mammamia lati che giocato e giocatore
sei giocatori sono anche i giocatori mi
chiamo carisma don alberto ferrando
facevo una carrucola usa la carrucola
aspetta rimani lato poi aveva un pazzo a
luca sapori formaggio occhio ragazzi
bravi che siamo ma bisogna che qualcuno
ancora carrucola ricorda nella
spaccatura c'è francesco
di tirarla giù pro teano logico e giusto
però che erano entrati ai apporto del
male ma perché ci stanno sfide scriverò
laterale picchia forte non campa di
questi ha posto a posto
bene anche l'altro non aspettano
l'ultimo bozzano di beyeler weiler
aspetta aspetta che vale ma dovete
correre a quella dove fu pure corrente
correte quella dopo quella dopo subito
vai dritto
mamma mia
quando c'è ok ce l'ha fatta di forma mia
albarello là di questa giunta da 6 mila
schede ragazzi cosa vedo
ho mai dato io che figata
da piccoli e cosa egp è ancora vivo
quindi sì ma come ora aggiungiamo le
pietre metà parlava il mercato è
scappato portiere della rabbia
cosa vi a farci ma questo forziere
restituisci il forziere di di striscia
dea dobbiamo tornare alla nave
riportarlo al fantasma quello di prima
che ce la tramissione brano sono ci sono
di ok va in escandescenze
dice un teschio bravo ma c'è una cassa
di munizioni quindi potrebbe esserci
qualcuno del 6 al di sotto una cascata
di acquisto scheletri domenica ma non ci
grilli no ma ucciso porca miseriaccia
adesso non lo prendo io di pathos e che
non ci devono spingere in mano
abbiamo toccato vivo però aiuto adesso
io avrò a porta cosa fare
sono arrivato alla porta
eccomi eccomi regalare come aiuto
motivando sta arrivando ai regali come
cazzo si arrivò li aiuta
vivoli madonna si è allora 26 di sanità
si è certo che i beni sono dopo il pezzo
dell'acqua e ti aspetti mi aspetto che
ci sono come come questo ti ho dentro di
me ci arriva
dove state di recente ho io se l'acqua è
l'acqua l'acqua cacchia cascata mica
l'ho vista mi sa che usciamo è una
cagata
e se si esce se grande boss
pensa se entravamo d'acqua adesso slope
le dico ok ok chi è quello harry potter
beh mi chiamo castoriadis teacher dato
harry potter veramente facendo il
rispetto patron ma ora quante piero
longo in centro a bada che
la coltre che via via occhio inesperto
patron vedi a mamma e papà david o le
due fantagenitori questo artista spada
[Musica]
avete è finita così bene e vita
e dove sono i nostri sono stati bravi o
raga io pensavo ci fosse un boss finale
io pure insomma il lupo no era solo a
campare delle trump ne avrebbe fatto più
effetto perché dell'altra destinare a
tale va tutto bene vero
[Musica]